you have a lot of tattoos in your left  arm  and probably having your rights strictly  for buckets  so that same same deal thousand percent  did you get the inspiration from dick  young yes sir  walk me through like when when you  decided to make that happen like how old  were you  17.  okay and you've been adding to your left  arm since 17  and you will not put anything on your  right arm no sir  do you remember where you were when you  heard that nick young thing what what  how you saw it did you ever talk to nick  about it i never talked to him about it  man i was in high school uh  just starting to get tatted and i heard  him say that man i'm like oh yeah  yeah  it's my turn now  yes sir dan  blake have you taken any other life  advice from nick no that's it no no no  no no